non-minimalists
what are you what are you afraid of what
am i afraid we're talking about fear
today we've got some questions about
fear but
what do you think about everything man
everything i'm afraid of failure
okay i'm afraid of rejection i'm afraid
of not being significant i'm afraid of
people falling out of love with me i'm
afraid of uh everything dude
i mean there's i'm i'm a you know i know
that i come across as pretty confident
but um it's like if i don't have that
confidence then i would just i just
you know crawl on a ball and like you
know just
hide from society i guess man yeah
because that that's the alternative and
it's not a pretty alternative
it's not a meaningful alternative no
it's not one that you'll find purpose or
joy
in either you might find a momentary
pacification
or momentary comfort or maybe long-term
comfort but that's often the problem
comfort is the place where we go and die
it's really comfortable in that grave
and and we don't experience
i don't experience life there quite
literally but also figuratively
i kind of but you know what's great
about
any of those fears like when you can
overcome the fear man like it feels so
good
like land in that jump i mean
i don't think i would i wouldn't i would
not hit that same jump again
even though i landed it like i would not
be like oh
oh no i can hit that jump every single
time remember our friend
uh but the feeling of accomplishment was
just like overwhelmingly awesome
our friend leo babalta wrote a blog post
years ago called joy fear he made up
this new word
yeah and it reminds me what you're
talking about getting to the other side
of that fear
is where the accomplishment the joy
comes from
quite often and i think about we took
remember earlier this year we we took
ella
down to uh disneyland uh and also your
friend's daughter
uh what was her name um little zoey yeah
zoe yeah kelsey's kid we took yeah zoey
it was ella
and then um olia her son yeah yeah
um the first part we took him to was
pinocchio
come on that's the first ride we took
him too they were terrified yeah
dude yeah like of geppetto and
things they weren't supposed to be
terrified of right but what i'm
remembering is
uh and you can actually i think you can
still find this on my personal instagram
it's
at joshua fields millburn yes uh under
the highlights of ella
there's this photo of it's we we
got on the log flume what was it called
uh i forget what it's called
splash mountain yeah it's flash mountain
and we're and it's me bex and ella in
this car together and you can see me i'm
up front like ah
and uh right behind me is ella and the
look on her face is
perfectly encapsulated with that one
more joy fear she is on the edge of
terror
but also on the edge of elation
yeah hysteria extreme
joy i'm just thinking about that picture
dude that is well and then
i zoomed in can we put a link to that
yeah i think so
sean if you can at least put a link to
my instagram you can find the highlights
there at the top i believe
uh it was an instagram story that i put
up uh i actually had to buy the photo
off of them because they took it off of
the thing and yeah
but anyway uh and then i zoomed in but
you could really see the joy
fear on her face yeah and what a perfect
metaphor in order to experience the joy
you have to get through that for you
have to push right right against the
edge it wasn't
so terrifying that it was a terrible
experience so let's keep that in mind
she wanted to write it again
well during it she was on the edge of
like oh my god i don't know if i want
this
right but as she got to the other side
then it was
i have to do this again right i have to
do it again
all right well we do have some questions
today hold on what are you scared of
oh nothing you're you're bulletproof
let me i'm just terrified of
90s white rappers because they will slay
your ass yeah i'm just thinking you know
jojo pellegrino and he would tear you up
in a rap battle bone and
seriously man what are you scared of
dude um well i think my answer to this a
few years ago would have been different
from
from now i used to be really afraid
of being forgotten whether it was in
personal relationships
or in writing or whatever but it's
such an irrational fear because if you
pan out far enough
we're all going to be forgotten right
george washington is going to be
forgotten
henry david thoreau is going to be
forgotten seneca
is going to be forgotten on a long
enough timeline jesus and buddha and
muhammad are all going to be
forgotten and so of course i'm going to
be forgotten yeah too
right uh you pan out long enough what 10
000 years from now 100 000 years from
now it doesn't
doesn't matter there's some time frame
where all of humanity is going to be
forgotten so you're not scared of
anything now well no i mean
what i'm saying is that helped me sort
of put it in perspective to
a great extent like there are rational
fears and there are
irrational fears and a lot of my my
fears
now whenever i come across them i
realize how irrational
they are it's the fear of not being
significant
it is quite often that that that is an
extension of what we just
what i was just talking about there but
it's often like well i want to be
significant i want to do something
but really what i'm saying there is i
want to do something meaningful while
i am here yeah it's not a fear of being
forgotten it's not a fear of not being
significant it's a fear of
wasting my time really